This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Trophies are hard for people to throw away. There's actually a service in medicine Wisconsin that will recycle your old trophies and turn them into new ones. They replace the name plates they polish them up and then donate them to nonprofits like the Boys and Girls Club or the Special Olympics. Some of the trophies they get come from people who have passed away. They're surviving relatives in them. And sometimes they're from people who are just tired of their trophies taking up space in their homes. In both cases, people will actually pay the shipping to Madison to avoid putting their trophies
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。人们很难狠下心扔掉奖杯。事实上，威斯康星州麦迪逊市有一家机构，会回收你的旧奖杯并把它们重塑成新奖杯。他们会更换铭牌、打磨抛光，然后把它们捐赠给诸如男女孩童俱乐部或特殊奥林匹克运动会等非营利组织。他们收到的部分奖杯来自于已经过世的人，是由他们的在世亲属送来的。有时，这些奖杯则来自于那些厌倦了奖杯在家中占据空间的人。在这两种情况下，人们甚至愿意支付运费将奖杯寄到麦迪逊，以便避免把它们
in the trash. Donna Gray, who runs this service with her daughter Janet, says that sometimes people request to be told where their old trophies end up, almost like they're donating an organ. Most of the time, the materials that make them are cheap, but that's not how you measure the value of a trophy. There's a little trophy shop down the street from our office in Oakland. It's small, but bustling, and it's windows are stuffed to the brim with awards made of all kinds of materials and in any shape you can imagine. Chalices, orbs, golfers, gaffles, apples, and plaques. Plenty of plaques. So of course producer Avery Truffleman read them.
扔进垃圾桶。唐娜·格雷与她的女儿珍妮一同经营着这项服务，她表示，有时人们会要求获知他们旧奖杯最终的去向，几乎就像是在捐献器官一样。大多数时候，制作这些奖杯的材料很廉价，但衡量奖杯价值的方式并非如此。在我们奥克兰办公室的街角，有一家小型奖杯店。它虽然狭小却很热闹，橱窗里塞满了各种材质、各种你能想象到形状的奖杯和奖品。高脚杯、球体、高尔夫球手、高尔夫球棍、苹果以及牌匾。有大量的牌匾。因此，我们的制作人埃弗里·特鲁夫曼自然而然地读了读上面的字。
We the membership of Mount Zion Log number, present this token of appreciation to Brother Willie Adams. We honor and welcome you. I'm Freeman Asin. And I allow to reveal who that is. Honorable Award of Excellence presented to Gavin Newsom, Mayor of San Francisco, an appreciation for your contributions to the Nigerian community. Club DJ of the year in 1990.
我们锡安山洛格分会的全体会员，向威利·亚当斯兄弟颁发此纪念品以表谢意。我们向您致以敬意并表示欢迎。我是弗里曼·阿辛。我获准透露那是谁。卓越荣誉奖，颁发给旧金山市长加文·纽森，以感谢您对尼日利亚社区做出的贡献。1990年度俱乐部DJ。
There's one that says rifle expert. In there are plenty of touchingly heartfelt engravings that you feel that maybe you shouldn't be reading. To my dear husband, Gil, on the occasion of our 35th wedding anniversary, thank you, sweetheart, for 35 loving, supportive, challenging, and exciting years together. God has knitted our hearts together into a beautiful tapestry of love. Julia Radell runs this shop along with her husband, and she's always moved by what people want engraved on their trophies. People amaze me with eloquence and the sincerity and just the way that they can express their feelings.
其中有一个上面写着“步枪专家”。里面还有许多触动人心的深情刻字，让你觉得也许自己本不该去读它们。致我亲爱的丈夫吉尔，在我们结婚35周年纪念日之际，谢谢你，亲爱的，感谢你35年来给予我的充满爱意、支持、充满挑战且令人兴奋的岁月。上帝将我们的心编织成了一幅美丽的爱之织锦。朱莉娅·拉德尔和她的丈夫一起经营着这家店，对于人们希望在奖杯上刻下什么内容，她总是深为感动。人们的口才、真诚以及他们表达情感的方式总是让我惊叹。
Because I am from the culture where people did not express their feelings publicly. Julia is from Russia. And it was not always appreciated when people would just express sincerely their feelings, let alone have them engraved and be displayed publicly. Russians just don't give out trophies the way that we do. Americans freaking love trophies. And some of the fanciest trophies in Julius shop, actually some of the fanciest trophies in the world, come from RS Owens in company in Chicago.
因为我来自一个人们不会公开表达情感的文化背景。朱莉娅来自俄罗斯。过去，人们如果只是真诚地表达情感，往往不会受到赞赏，更不用说把它们刻下来公开展示了。俄罗斯人根本不像我们这样颁发奖杯。美国人简直爱死奖杯了。朱莉娅店里一些最华丽的奖杯，实际上也是世界上最华丽的奖杯，来自于芝加哥的RS欧文斯公司。
My father built the company and his first figure was a guinea pig figure that he manufactured. For guinea pig breeding competitions during the Great Depression, RS Owens has since moved well beyond the humble Guinea Pig trophy. Scott Seagal's father was the founder of RS Owens and Company, and Scott showed me around the factory, like a real bonafide factory with big kilns for the glass plaques and wheeled carts full of castings
我父亲创立了这家公司，他制造的第一座小金人是一个豚鼠造型。在经济大萧条时期，这是为豚鼠繁育比赛制作的。此后，RS欧文斯早已远远超越了那座朴素的豚鼠奖杯。斯科特·西格尔的父亲是RS欧文斯公司的创始人，斯科特带我参观了他们的工厂，这是一座名副其实的真正工厂，里面有用于玻璃牌匾的大型窑炉，有装满铸件的推车，
and statuettes and rows and rows of industrial grade buffers. This is just some of what we do here. Their massive showroom is full of crazy different kinds of trophies and awards. This was for NASCAR. This is the only time we've made an award with a built-in DVD player. gimmicks aside, RSOans make some truly iconic trophies. That's the Emmy over there. Yes, an Emmy award.
还有小雕像，以及一排又一排工业级的抛光机。这只是我们在这里所做工作的一部分。他们巨大的展厅里摆满了各种疯狂的不同类型的奖杯和奖品。这个是为纳斯卡赛车制作的。这是我们唯一一次制作内置DVD播放器的奖项。抛开噱头不谈，RS欧文斯确实制作了一些标志性的奖杯。那边那个是艾美奖。没错，就是一个艾美奖。
But the Emmy is outshined by its neighbor. I can't believe that's a real Oscar. The Oscar's real name is the Academy Award of Merit, but is now officially known by its nickname. There's lots of mythology around where the name Oscar came from, but the official myth is that the Academy librarian Margaret Herrick took a look at the statue in whispered, he looks like my uncle Oscar. The first Oscar was awarded in 1929 and a number of different factories have manufactured the Oscars over the years. RS Owens has been making them since 1983.
但艾美奖的光芒却被它的邻居盖过了。我简直不敢相信那是一个真的奥斯卡。奥斯卡的正式名称是学院功绩奖，但现在人们更习惯用它的昵称来称呼它。关于“奥斯卡”这个名字的由来流传着许多神话，但官方的说法是，电影艺术与科学学院的图书管理员玛格丽特·赫里克看了一眼这座雕像，低声说：他看起来就像我的叔叔奥斯卡。第一座奥斯卡奖颁发于1929年，多年来有许多不同的工厂制造过奥斯卡奖。RS欧文斯公司自1983年起开始生产它们。
When I saw the Oscar, it was hard to believe that I was looking at the real deal because I'd seen so many knockoffs. The design itself isn't hard to imitate, it's really simple. It's mostly just that style as gold man standing on a real film. Actually, MGMR director Cedric Gibbons originally designed the statue as a night gripping a crusader's sword. And the Oscar has been purposefully designed to be as desirable an object as possible. There's more gold on the Oscar than any other award by far.
当我看到奥斯卡奖时，很难相信自己看到的是真品，因为我见过太多山寨货了。设计本身并不难模仿，它非常简单。主要就是一个金色小人站在一卷真正的胶卷上。事实上，米高梅公司的导演塞德里克·吉本斯最初将这座雕像设计成了一个手握十字军长剑的骑士。奥斯卡奖在设计上一直刻意使其成为尽可能令人向往的物品。奥斯卡奖上的黄金含量远远超过任何其他奖项。
There's more gold on the Oscar than any other award we make. Also it's really hefty. It's 8.5 pounds and it's crazy shiny. A lot of polishing goes into what obviously it has to be defect free. So that takes a lot of time. How much time? To polish each one over an hour. Oh man, when I saw it, I just wanted it. It was like primal almost. But somehow Scotty go resist the urge to make one for himself. A lot of people ask me about whether I have an Asgard home and are surprised that I don't. I've never even been interested in having an Oscar at home.
奥斯卡奖上的黄金含量远超我们制作的任何其他奖项。此外，它确实很重。它重达8.5磅，而且闪闪发光得惊人。为了达到显然必须完美无瑕的效果，其中包含了大量的抛光工序。这需要花费大量时间。需要多长时间？对每一个进行抛光都需要一个多小时。天哪，当我看到它时，我只想拥有它。那几乎是一种原始的冲动。但斯科特·西格尔不知怎的克制住了为自己做一个的冲动。很多人问我家里有没有奥斯卡奖，并对我说没有感到惊讶。我甚至从未对家里摆一个奥斯卡奖感兴趣。
That's exactly what he would say if he had an Oscar at home. But some people do make awards for themselves. People do make awards for themselves. Back in Oakland, Julia gets customers who don't look very athletic at all, picking up trophies that say they are number one in running, or elderly customers buying a trophy for being a young beauty queen queen or world traveler. And this has happened multiple times. Yeah, oh yes, quite multiple.
如果他家里真有一个奥斯卡奖，他大概就会这么说。但有些人确实会为自己制作奖项。人们确实会为自己制作奖项。回到奥克兰，朱莉娅迎来的顾客看起来一点也不像运动员，他们来取刻有自己是跑步第一名的奖杯，或者有老年顾客买奖杯奖励自己曾是年轻的选美皇后或世界旅行者。而且这种情况发生过不止一次。是的，哦，是的，相当多次。
Yes, it's a common thing. Julia is so not judgmental about this. If giving yourself an award makes you feel better, she's all for it. It's a way of validating your own experience. And even more validating than making yourself an award is making yourself an entire awards ceremony. Welcome to MTV Music Television. Young MTV decided to establish itself with an awards ceremony, because that's a great
是的，这是一件很常见的事。朱莉娅对此一点也不评判。如果给自己颁奖能让你感觉好受些，她双手赞成。这是一种肯定你自身经历的方式。而比给自己颁奖更具肯定意义的，是为自己举办一整场颁奖典礼。欢迎来到MTV音乐电视台。年轻的MTV决定通过一场颁奖典礼来确立自己的地位，因为这是一个绝佳的
way to quickly attract a lot of viewers, get high ratings, and bring in a lot of star power. And they wanted to further establish themselves with a really good trophy. I'm Pat Gorman, and I designed the Moonman statue. That silver astronaut given out at the MTV Video Music Awards, or VMAs. Pat Gorman was part of Manhattan Design, the firm that created the MTV logo, but making this trophy fulfilled a long time dream of hers. I had been a champion baton tourler with my sister.
途径，可以迅速吸引大量观众、获得高收视率并引入强大的明星阵容。并且他们希望通过一座真正优秀的奖杯来进一步巩固自身地位。我是帕特·戈尔曼，我设计了月球人雕像。也就是在MTV音乐录影带大奖（简称VMA）上颁发的那个银色宇航员。帕特·戈尔曼是曼哈顿设计公司的成员，该公司创作了MTV的标志，但制作这座奖杯实现了她长久以来的梦想。我曾和姐姐一起拿过双人棍棒杂耍比赛的冠军。
We had like a doubles routine and we have all these little awards at home and I thought, I wanted to make a great trophy sometime in my life and then this would be a chance. So Manhattan design kicked around a few ideas, but eventually Pat realized that the perfect trophy would be a statue of a man on the moon. Ladies and gentlemen, Rock'n'Roll. For those of you who weren't around, Avery, MTV played a little station ID clip with it off the hour. We're the man lands on the moon and plants the MTV flag.
我们有一个双人表演节目，家里有各种各样的小奖杯，当时我就想，我这一生中一定要制作一座伟大的奖杯，而这就是一个机会。于是曼哈顿设计公司推敲了几个创意，但最终帕特意识到，最完美的奖杯应该是一个登月之人的雕像。女士们先生们，摇滚乐。对于那些没有经历过那个时代的人来说，埃弗里，MTV会在整点时播放一个小型的电台台标短片。画面中宇航员登上月球并插上了MTV的旗帜。
It was vintage footage of the moon landing, but instead of planting an American flag, the astronaut had a flag that said MTV. I thought, well, let's use that as the statue. And I also wanted to make the statue look like it was floating. So Pat designed an astronaut figure in a wrinkly Apollo suit balancing on one leg holding a little flag that said MTV. She drives some sketches and she gave them to a manufacturer and then she comes back two weeks later.
那是登月时期的老档案画面，但宇航员插的不是美国国旗，而是一面写着MTV的旗帜。我想，好吧，我们就把它用作雕像的造型吧。而且我还希望这座雕像看起来像是在悬浮。于是帕特设计了一个穿着皱巴巴的阿波罗宇航服、单脚站立、手里拿着一面写有MTV的小旗子的宇航员形象。她画了几张草图，把它们交给了一家制造商，两周后她回来了。
And he says, here's your statue. I look and it didn't look anything. It was, there was a guy standing with his feet firmly planted and he's saluting. I said, what's he saluting? There's nothing there. Pat's like, this is totally unacceptable. You've got to follow my sketch and the manufacturer goes back to work. We come back in a week and now is she something even more bizarre?
制造商说，这是你的雕像。我看了一眼，发现它完全不像。那是一个双脚稳稳站立、正在敬礼的家伙。我问，他在敬礼什么？那里什么都没有。帕特心想，这完全不可接受。你必须按照我的草图来做，于是制造商又回去工作了。我们过了一周回去，结果他做出了更离奇的东西吗？
I see a man in a week and now is she something even more bizarre? I see a man in a leisure suit. He's got this whole thing smoothed out. There's not a wrinkle in the suit. Also this leisure suit moonman was still not on one leg and the manufacturer insisted. Nope. Can't happen. It won't balance.
我看到一个男人，过了一周后，他做出了更离奇的东西吗？我看到一个身穿休闲西装的男人。他把整套衣服都熨得平平整整。衣服上连一丝褶皱都没有。而且这个休闲西装月球人依然不是单脚站立，制造商还坚称。不行。做不到。它无法保持平衡。
We only have one more week and that's it and they've got to be cast like tomorrow. So I just asked him for clay and he started building it. Pat teamed up with a friend who was a potter. And they made a mold of the guy standing on one leg holding the MTV flag and it balanced. There's a thing about balance where if you line up the head, the center of the belly and the center of the foot, You can balance in almost any posture. And so I just did that, and it was perfect. But the manufacturer really didn't have a lot of time at this point.
我们只剩下一周时间了，就是这样，而且明天就得开始铸造。所以我只好向他要了粘土，自己开始捏造起来。帕特与一位身为陶艺家的朋友合作。他们制作了一个单脚站立、手持MTV旗帜的男子模具，而且它真的能平衡。关于平衡有一个诀窍，只要把头部、腹部中心和脚部中心排在一条直线上，你几乎可以用任何姿势保持平衡。于是我照着做了，效果完美。但此时制造商确实没有多少时间了。
And he only got around to making five trophies right before the very first ever video music awards. And there were about 30 awards that were going to be given out. So what do we do? They decided that an usher could take each winner off the stage and fetch the moonman each time and then bring it back on stage during a commercial break. And this meant they could just keep recycling those same five trophies throughout the course of the night.
就在首届视频音乐大奖开幕前夕，他紧赶慢赶也只做出了五座奖杯。而当时大约有30个奖项要颁发。那该怎么办呢？他们决定让一位引座员在每次颁奖时把获奖者带下舞台，每次都去取回月球人，然后在广告期间把它带回台上。这意味着他们可以在当晚的整个过程中反复循环使用那仅有的五座奖杯。
We'll never run out. So I thought that was brilliant. Yes, at the very first VMAs there were only five trophies and they didn't tell anyone. What could possibly go wrong? Disaster struck. Michael Jackson, Thriller. Michael Jackson wasn't there sadly at the first one but he won all these awards for Thriller. Diana Ross was sitting in the front and she was accepting them for him.
我们永远不会用完。所以我认为这太妙了。没错，在首届VMA上只有五座奖杯，而且他们没有告诉任何人。能出什么岔子呢？灾难降临了。迈克尔·杰克逊，《颤栗》。遗憾的是，迈克尔·杰克逊并没有出席首届颁奖典礼，但他凭借《颤栗》赢得了所有这些奖项。戴安娜·罗斯坐在前排，代他上台领奖。
Well I talked to Michael today and he wants me first to thank you, John. Diana Ross, right in the front row, would go up and down the stairs before the usher could take her off the stage and get the moonman from her. And Thriller kept winning more and more awards. And the winner is Michael Jackson, who's Thriller. You won a lot in a row, and she had all five statues in her lap. So they sent an usher to sneak down to Diana Ross and take the statues back. And she starts fighting with him.
嗯，我今天跟迈克尔谈过了，他首先让我谢谢你，约翰。坐在最前排的戴安娜·罗斯，在引座员能够将她带下舞台并拿走她手中的月球人之前，就已经自己上下起台阶了。而且《颤栗》不断赢得更多的奖项。获奖者是迈克尔·杰克逊的《颤栗》。你接连赢了好多次奖，她的膝盖上堆满了全部五座雕像。于是他们派了一名引座员偷偷走到戴安娜·罗斯身边，把雕像拿回来。而她开始跟他抢了起来。
Stands up as I remember, it was like a tug of war. And it was like a real disaster. And the Moonman tug of war got a little bit of air time and it was embarrassing. But history has mostly forgotten it because much crazier things have since happened at the VMAs Thank you so much for giving me a chance to win a VMA award No Taylor, I'm really happy for you. I'm let you finish but Beyoncé had one of the best videos of all time Controversy has become its yearly tradition the whole event worked You know and I knew that if it was successful then it would would go on. It would become like a yearly thing a tradition
据我记忆所致，她站起身来，就像是在拔河一样。这简直是一场真正的灾难。而月球人拔河赛也在电视上播出了那么一小会儿，令人尴尬。但历史大多已经淡忘了这件事，因为自那以后，VMA上发生了更多更疯狂的事情。非常感谢你们给我机会赢得VMA奖项。不，泰勒，我真的为你感到高兴。我让你说完，但碧昂斯的MV是有史以来最好的MV之一。争议已成为它每年的传统，整个活动最终成功了。你知道的，我知道只要它成功，它就会延续下去。它会变成一年一度的传统。
Which it actually has and the movement is stayed which is kind of amazing Honestly now that MTV is without music and almost without traditional television This award ceremony has become a big part of MTV's identity and by now they figured out how to get all the winners Their own personalized awards was it's actually a lot harder to plan than you think especially when you get into the high stakes award, like the Oscars. Because back in Chicago, RS Owens doesn't know in advance who the Oscar winners are,
事实也确实如此，月球人的形象也保留了下来，这真是挺神奇的。老实说，如今MTV没有了音乐，几乎也没有了传统电视节目，这场颁奖典礼已经成为MTV身份认同中不可或缺的一部分，到现在他们已经知道如何让所有获奖者都拿到他们专属的个性化奖项了。这其实比你想象的要难得多，尤其是当你涉足像奥斯卡这样备受瞩目的高风险奖项时。因为在芝加哥，RS欧文斯公司并不知道谁会提前获得奥斯卡奖，
so they've developed a smart solution. Because there's so few Oscars given out and there's so few nominees, we just can grave plates for all the nominees. And the Academy can just quickly screw on the nameplate of the winner and destroy the other nameplates. It's a lot of effort, but then the winners get to have awards that are already personalized.
所以他们想出了一个聪明的解决方案。由于颁发的奥斯卡奖很少，提名者也很少，我们只需为所有提名者都刻好铭牌。学院可以在获奖者产生后迅速把获奖者的铭牌拧上去，并销毁其余的铭牌。这需要付出很多努力，但这样一来，获奖者就能拿到已经印有自己名字的奖项。
Because the most important thing about an award is that it has your name on it. I think it was Carnegie who said that the one word that the person would always prefer over all the other words in the vocabulary is his name. Dale Carnegie's Principle number six from how to win friends and influence people is remember that a person's name is to that person the sweetest and most important sound in any language. That goes a long way into the into the award business as well because people see their names not only here, it's said, but they actually see it engraved.
因为奖项最重要的一点就是上面刻着你的名字。我想是卡耐基曾说过，一个人在所有词汇中最偏爱的那个词永远是他的名字。戴尔·卡耐基从《人性的弱点》中总结出的第六大原则是：记住，对于任何人来说，任何语言中甜美、最重要的声音都是他们自己的名字。这一点在奖项业务中同样大有裨益，因为人们不仅在这里听到自己的名字被宣读，还能亲眼看到它被镌刻在上面。
Okay, with that said, I'd like to present an award of recognition for producer of this episode to Avery Trophing me. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh, there's so many people to thank. I'd like to thank Franco Linsky, who really helped me fact check and reach out to Pat Gorman.
好吧，话虽如此，我谨向本集节目的制作人埃弗里·特鲁芬·米颁发一个表彰奖。天哪。天哪。哦，有太多人需要感谢了。我要感谢弗兰科·林斯基，他真正帮我核实了事实并联系上了帕特·戈尔曼。
I'd really also like to thank Fred Sebert. Oh my god, who else is there? I'd really like to thank Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle. You guys are the best. Roman Mars, thank you for making this all happen. This wouldn't happen without you. And KLW, the best public radio station, Arxine architecture and interiors, you make such beautiful buildings,
我还要特别感谢弗雷德·西伯特。天哪，还有谁呢？我真的要感谢萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔。你们是最棒的。罗曼·马尔斯，谢谢你促成了这一切。没有你，这一切都不会发生。还有KLW，最好的公共广播电台，Arxine建筑与室内设计事务所，你们建造了如此美丽的建筑，
and always leave, you know, you always have like chocolate lying around for us. Thank you, thank you so much. And okay, thank you. Thank you all. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. All the whole staff are all on Twitter and super fascinating there. But we have pictures and comments on every show we've ever made. And 99pi.org.
而且总是留下，你知道的，你们总是为我们准备好巧克力。谢谢，非常感谢。好的，谢谢。谢谢大家。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。全体工作人员都在推特上，那里超级有趣。但我们在我们制作过的每一个节目上都有图片和评论。网址是99pi.org。
Everyone in Radio Topia, just the whole Radio Topia family, you just make me want to be a better producer. You know my mom and my dad, my sister. Radio Topia. From PRX. RADIO TIPIUM from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio Topia的每个人，整个Radio Topia家族，你们让我渴望成为一名更优秀的制作人。你知道的，我的妈妈、我的爸爸、我的姐姐。Radio Topia。来自PRX。来自PRX的RADIO TIPIUM。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。